How to make better small talk with absolutely
anyone? I'm Chad Littlefield but in this video,
I'm going to highlight Brandon Stanton. You
might not know his name but you probably know
humans of New York which is the movement
and the project that Brandon Stanton created
and in this video, I'm going to unpack. I got to
meet Brandon Stanton and connect with him and
hear him speak and he shared some brilliant
brilliant brilliant ideas that can help all
of us get so much better with small talk. So if you
choose to watch this video to the end you will not
be able to actually be in a
conversation that stays at small talk.
Brandon Stanton who's about nine feet
tall when you actually meet him in person.
So if you're not familiar with humans of
New York google it first of all it's a wonderful
little internet rabbit hole of humanity. The basic
idea is he wanted to take photographic census
of New York City. You want to take portraits of
everyone in New York City. Obviously, never get to
everyone. I don't know what his count is up to but
it's definitely over 10,000 people at this point
which is holy smokes a lot of people. This is years
and years and years of taking people's portraits
but he did it in a really fun and unique way. When
he posted the portraits to originally Facebook and
other social media. He would post their photo
which are all really phenomenal showing really
eclectic diverse interesting people that just the
photo itself tells a story. But he goes one step
further as he's taking portrait of them he also
asks them questions. He sparks up some small talk
and he includes with their photo just kind of a
line from the middle of their story. So, meaning,
a quote something that they actually said in the
middle of their conversation. Now, when I met him
and I heard him speak he shared the process that
he actually goes through to get to really great
parts of the story. Because if you just show up
to somebody in the middle of New York and you're
like, "Hey, like tell me something interesting about
yourself", it's quite unlikely that they're going to
tell you this like, really heartfelt amazing story
about their grandmother when they were five years
old. But when you pair a story about someone
who was five years old hanging out with their
grandmother and their picture is of like a nine
foot tattooed motorcycle dude covered in leather.
The amount of depth that it gives that
person is huge and so there's lots of value of
being able to go beyond the surface and so the way
that he described it was the helicopter method.
It was this idea that a helicopter when it's landing.
So when it gets to its final destination. The
rotors are spinning really really really really
fast and they're spiraling as it's going down as
it's going down. So sometimes in conversation it
kind of feels like you're in the circular pattern
but you're moving vertically. You're actually
getting depth as you're going. So, that's
about the extent that Brandon Stanton explained this
helicopter method. It was just kind of the metaphor
of like you have to dive deeper and deeper into
conversation. But me and my co-founder will really
like to think about how to ask powerful questions
and create conversations that matter and so we
took that metaphor a step further and said, "Okay,
what does that actually mean?", like taking it
out of metaphor land. What does it actually mean
to spin the blade around and to go lower like how
do you actually do that? And so, to add a metaphor
think about ping pong. If I was curious about that
motorcycle guy's story with his grandmother. I'm
gonna focus on that one element and I'm gonna
toss a question like a little ping pong ball
back about that one experience and then he'll
fire back with something and then that will spark
some new experience and it kind of ping-pongs back
and forth or in Brandon's where he spirals down.
The point is I'm gonna bounce around a ton of
questions maybe to a whole handful of topics.
But when I finally get low enough in the helicopter
to see my destination or see the x on the ground
or the helipad where I need to land or in reality
it's not a helipad right it is a topic that
ignites your curiosity. The way that you eradicate
small talk is to be voraciously curious about
whatever that person has to share. Okay, if the
helicopter and the ping pong aren't working for you.
Think about when you google search something.
So if you want to find something that's really
really interesting that goes beyond small talk.
Let's say you want to learn all about Genghis
khan. You don't know a lot about Genghis Khan
and so you google Genghis Khan. what you're
going to do when you google Genghis Khan
is you're going to type in his name press enter
and Google's going to feedback a couple hundred
million results for you and you're going to scroll
through and find the one that piques your interest
the most and you're going to click on that.
And then you're going to look around that page
there might be a couple videos and a foot well,
maybe not videos of Genghis Khan. A couple photos
some articles and there's gonna be some
hyperlinks there and you're gonna click again
and you're gonna go a little bit deeper and then
you're gonna click again and this is what we call
an internet rabbit hole. You started with
Genghis Khan and who knows where you ended up.
If you want to get really good at small talk
stay focused on Genghis Khan. Stay focused on
one thing and keep being curious about that
and circling around back to it connecting it
to other things. Don't end up on TikTok
when you started with Genghis Khan stay in the
place stay focused on whatever it is that
you're naturally genuinely curious about
and keep asking questions from different
angles to that. Because if you do that
you go deeper in conversation vertically rather
than horizontally bouncing around everywhere.
The reason we get off of an internet rabbit hole
and we feel like kind of exhausted and empty
is because we didn't get anywhere. We just like
skimmed around on the surface. We never got to
any level of depth. Whereas if you spent a whole
10 hours researching one single topic compared
to most of the population, you'd be a master at
that topic and so one way to bring out somebody's
mastery is to stay deep ask more about that. So if
they've mentioned that they're a nuclear engineer
you could then ask them where they're from and
bounce over here. But if you're curious about
the engineer part ask them how they got into that.
Ask them what one of the scariest things they
experience as a nuclear engineer? Ask that.
Continue asking them questions on whatever really
ignited your curiosity. I'm really transparent.
before I hit record on this video I said to
Steven my master filmographer was like,
"I feel like I've recorded 17 video tutorials on how
to create small talk", and yet it's a frequently
asked question because it's so present everybody
experiences it. 98% of the human beings I've ever
met would be totally happy taking small talk
and swapping it out for conversations that matter.
Things that they really care about or things
that the people are talking to really care about.
Because when you talk to somebody who's interested
and treated and passionate it's so much better
than social chit chat because we're obligated to
fill the space. I say that as an invite because if
you enjoyed any piece of this you can get a free
excerpt of our book that dives way deeper into
this. But you can also just google my name Chad
Littlefield small talk and Chad Littlefield small
yard, Chat Littlefield small talk, and you'll get a
ton of different videos that take different angles
and share some really practical insights and tips
on how to go from small talk to conversations
that matter. I'm Chad, have an awesome day.